uh now last week we had some distressing
news it was announced
that arsenal were making their mascot
the gonosaurus
redundant do you do you know gonosaurus
of course you know of course
yes of course they work closely together
of course you do everything that
gonosaurus knows
yeah yeah yeah this was the art he was
talking about earlier
yeah the thing is it's odd you think
that arsenal would have
gonosaurus a dinosaur as their mascot
but that
is the world of mascots so here's a good
game everybody
guess the mascot from the football team
for example
what's the mascot for south end united
okay
remember they're on the coast what do
you think seagull
seagull's a good guess no it is of
course
sammy the shrimp it's either a shrimp
or some sort of gay shark
what about wigan does anyone know wigan
you like wiggins
wiggum is it a pie yes is it me it is a
pie
it's krusty the pie
unbelievable yeah that's the best
mascara ever
i know i bet that's a really grumpy
person inside
that very cheerful pie okay here's an
easy one we'll give this arsenal get
this one
the scottish football team partic
thistle what do you think their mascot
is
thistle i don't know what it is what
does it mean well
well it's a sort of it's a scottish
thorny flower but you will be no wiser
that's why
after seeing kingsley the thistle
the black is not a thistle it looks like
kenny to coronavirus it's
terrible i mean what a lovely photo op
for children
go and stand beside that
and uh finally west bromwich albion okay
come on arson you can get this one no no
i don't know the name of the flowers in
english no it's uh
west bromwich albion are the team the
baggies the baggies
no the the baggies they're all the bags
they used to have a big bag to collect
the takings in okay that's why they call
the baggies oh i didn't know
the baggies what do you think their
mascot is
i don't know anyone a bag
no it's a combi boiler
[Applause]
i'm sensing those sponsors
you